in this video we'll talk about the
helicobacter pilory infection
helicobacter pylori is a bacteria and it
infects the stomach that can cause
ulcers
about half the world population has
helicobacter pylori in their stomach but
not all of them show symptoms so let's
understand what are the symptoms of
helicobacter pilot infection
so the general symptom is ache and
burning sensation in the abdomen and it
worsens with the
when the stomach is empty other than
that nausea loss of appetite bloating
and weight loss is kind of other
symptoms of helicobacter pylori
infection let's talk about the transfer
route of helicobacter pylori
it could be fecal oral gastric oral it
would it could be water bone and in rare
cases it could be oral oral or zoonotic
mediated transfer
so once helicobacter pylori enters our
body it survives the harsh environment
in the stomach
and it kind of erodes the lining of the
stomach and ultimately it leads to
formation of a gastric ulcer or a
duodenal ulcer
now let's try to understand the
ulceration process in bit more details
and how helicobacter pylori can survive
in the harsh environment inside the
stomach here is the gastric mucosa and
you can see the mucosal lining which
contains of several epithelial cells and
several other cell types
now this is the thick layer of mucus and
even beyond the layer of mucus there
would be gastric hcl in the stomach
gastric hcl actually kills other
bacteria but helicobacter pylori can
survive in this extremely
low ph environment
and let me tell you how helicobacter
pylori actually produces one enzyme
known as urease which actually buffers
the
acidic environment inside the stomach
and let me tell you how
so the uleas enzyme can convert urea
into ammonia and ammonia being basic can
buffer the
immediate surrounding of the
helicobacter pylori and it can
create a somewhat basic environment that
allow the helicobacter pylori to survive
other than that helicobacter pylori
expresses some adhesion molecules known
as adhesins
this help the bacteria to attach to the
epithelial cells and infect them
helicobacterial pylori has
tufted flagella which helps in
chemotaxis and penetrate this thick
layer of mucus
other than that helicobacter pylori
secretes vac a and cag a which are
two
cytotoxins which are responsible for the
infection and the pathogenicity of this
bacterium
so vac a
can bind to the
membrane of the bacteria and
work as a adhesion molecule so it allows
the surface adhesion of this bacteria
vacay can also bind to specific
receptors on the gastric mucosal cells
and ultimately lead to an inflammatory
signal and it leads to production of
inflammatory cytokines which brings out
inflammation in this local region
vac a can also bind to the mitochondrial
membrane and allow the leakage of
cytochrome c so when cytochrome c is
released apoptosis is kind of triggered
now we understand in the gastric
mucosa there would be apoptosis of the
cells there would be inflammation and
all this lead to
further inflammation and leaking of the
gastric hcl into the mucosa which
ultimately leads to the
ulcer formation and
it gives you that pain sensation where
you when your stomach is empty
now let's talk about the diagnostic
tests for helicobacter pylori how it is
diagnosed there are a few tests such as
blood tests which checks the antibodies
of against h pylori in your blood
there is breadth test there are several
biomarkers in the brain which can give
us a sense that whether you are infected
with h pylori or not
there could be also stool test where you
provide your stool samples and the
antigen test looks for
helicobacter bilare antigen in the stool
but the best test for helicobacter
pylori is
endoscopy
here uh
here the doctor enters a endoscope
through your elementary canal and try to
visualize what happens in the stomach
and he takes a small portion of the
stomach and that is
that is then sampled for or acid for
helicobacter pylori so there are small
strips available
and which is used to perform urea's test
as i have mentioned already that
helicobacter pylori has urea's enzyme so
obviously here
in this particular spot there is urea so
if there is urease there would be
ammonia production and the indicator
which is present in this spot will
change the color
that simply boils down to if you have
red coloration that means you have
helicobacter pilot infection
and it's positive
but if the color comes to yellow that
means you don't have any infection
this is how we can rapidly understand
whether there is a infection of
helicobacter pylori or not let's talk
about treatment option
so obviously it's a bacteria then the
treatment option is
antibiotics but along with antibiotics
a proton pump inhibitor can reduce the
acidity in the
stomach and it can relieve the symptoms
of ulceration
among the common choice of antibiotics
amoxicillin
then
clarithromycin
metronidazole and tetracycline are some
of the
mostly used choices
but obviously it's important to consult
a doctor for his or her opinion in this
situation so i hope this video summarize
the basics of helicobacter pylori
infection if you like this video give it
a quick thumbs up and you can get the
notes and flash cards in the facebook
page
as usual don't forget to like share and
subscribe do let me know in the comment
whether these are useful for you
you can support my channel on patreon
i'm present in an academy which is
india's biggest online learning platform
you can take my courses by using my code
ap 10 you can get 10 percent discount i
am also present in other social media
links all the links are provided in the
description feel free to connect with me
and see you in next